Speaker 1: OK, let's start with something
that a lot of people have asked me to talk
about on the show, this is really interesting.
The latest right wing buzzword that's getting
people fired up and angry is critical race
theory.
Republicans are absolutely and completely
against the teaching of critical race theory
in schools.
They want to ban it.
They believe it's terrible.
It might even be communist or socialist.
It's really, really bad, but they don't actually
know what it is.
Check out this interview that Marc Lamont
Hill did with former Georgia Congressman Vernon
Jones, a Trumpy and favorite, who is really
against critical race theory, but he has no
idea what it is.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: What is critical race theory?
Well, actually, I think it's different depending
on who's teaching, how they're teaching.
I think you can agree with that.
We were taught that Christopher Columbus discovered
America.
Well, you and I both know that Christopher
Columbus got lost.
People are already living here.
But there are those who are using their own
ideology and their own party affiliation to
go to the extreme.
And that's what I'm trying to address.
But what does it have to do with critical
race?
Let me just ask I'm trying to understand why
you oppose critical race theory, which I understand.
I'm just asking, what is it?
What is the thing?
Define it like, for example, if I said I'm
against creationism, I would say creationism
is X, Y and Z.
Right.
If I said I was against the teaching of sex
education, I say, well, sex education is X,
Y and Z and I'd have a basis for it.
What is critical race theory?
Well, first of all, I can tell you left of
you understand, I can't make you understand.
The fact of it is the critical race theory,
even on this basis, should not be taught in
our schools, period.
Now, if you can't understand, what is it that
you want to debate?
Well, to me, what it does to me, my interpretation,
as well as many others know not what it does.
What is it?
How do you define it?
I mean, how to define critical race theory?
Because my audience may not know.
Well, so you don't know.
And you have obviously you don't know until
your audience.
But again, how I see it, I don't know, received.
Well then what is it not what is it.
OK, well I'm happy to answer that for you,
but your answer say I'll tell you what I will
absolutely.
To debate.
OK, I'm waiting for you to answer when I just
hold on one second.
You're you're saying that on day one.
On day one.
The question first ask the first question.
I promise I'll answer quickly
Speaker 1: so you get the picture.
Vernon Jones just doesn't know what it is.
That's just one example.
But this is the bottom line.
They continue to attack critical race theory
without actually indicating that they know
what it is when they're asked what it is they
seem to have no idea.
Or they say critical race theory is the idea
that every white person is a white supremacist
oppressor.
Now, we should understand what critical race
theory is.
And I want to be really clear that critical
race theory is not my primary lens through
which I view the world.
I find it reductionist, but I'm going to tell
you what critical race theory is and then
you can research more.
You can decide whether you think it's an accurate
lens or whether it should be part of your
worldview.
OK, the way I see critical race theory is
a sort of race reductionism.
Now, if you've heard the term class reductionism,
there's a very simple analogy to at least
give us an initial basic understanding of
critical race theory, although it's not nuanced
enough.
And I admit that class reductionists believe
that at some fundamental level, any division,
any problem, any conflict, any inequality
in society, in politics, in an economy, even
if it seems it might be caused by many things,
is actually about class, something that to
a class reduction is something that looks
like a racial issue to a class reductionist.
It's really a problem caused by class differences.
And the racial factors may just be confounding
or they may be coincidental or they may not
even be relevant.
So to make a very rough analogy, to give us
a start in understanding critical race theory,
critical race theory would analogously argue
that what might seem like a class problem
or an economic problem or a political problem,
that it is actually fundamentally a problem
of race and racism in the U.S. specifically,
it would be racism generally by white people
against nonwhite people, in particular against
black Americans.
Now, that's the most basic explanation.
It's far more detailed as an area of academic
research now for thirty years.
And really even more than that, the roots
of critical race theory are in the sixties
and seventies, but without getting into a
more nuanced definition, would include the
idea of creating subgroups of humans, developing
law and systems that are in.
Apparently racist and designed to maintain
these inequalities between whites and nonwhites,
and you can use that analysis when you look
at any system, you can look at the education
system through the lens of critical race theory
or the election system and on and on.
Now, there are undoubtedly many ways in which
aspects of critical race theory are completely
accurate.
Where I disagree with critical race theory,
much the same way I disagree with class reductionism
is that I don't think anything is quite so
simple on a planet of seven billion people,
in a country of three hundred and thirty one
million like the US, we can never really say
this issue is solely informed by one thing,
whether it's race, whether I've never found
an issue where race is the one lens through
which we understand it or class is the one
lens or geography is the one.
It's just never been that way on any issue
I've studied.
But this is not about my view.
This is about the reality that the very people
angrily denouncing critical race theory have
no idea what it even is.
Now, I want to say one other thing about that.
This is not uncommon.
Think about the usage of the term socialist
during the last presidential election.
I've asked lots of these people when I interview
them or when they call in or whatever.
What do you mean socialist?
And they have no idea what it means, but they
use it and they believe Joe Biden is one now
cartoonishly is one example.
Here's what happened when conservative Jesse
Lee Peterson brought it up when I visited
his studio in Los Angeles and the topic of
socialism came up during the Trump administration.
Take a look,
Speaker 3: because it is the straight, white,
conservative Christian man who's holding the
country together.
And if it wasn't for them, America would be
a socialist society already.
It would be a socialist society.
How would it be if you see if you notice the
average black man has no authority, no power
to Mexican, doesn't have any, is that white,
straight, conservative Christian man that
is preventing them from turning this country
into a socialist society?
But so here,
Speaker 1: let me ask you about this.
I'm not a socialist myself, I'm a social,
just to be clear, I'm not advocating for socialism.
I don't know that many actual socialists like
who would where's the big desire for the US
to become socialist?
Speaker 3: If you look at the Democratic Party,
there's almost no socialist in the Democrat
Socialist Communist Party.
Now, that's one that's one socialist idea
from the Democratic Party of socialized health
care.
Now, that's a socialist social democracy program.
No socialist.
And if you notice that Barack Obama, the father
messiah, you know, he's the father messiah.
Right?
I don't know anything about that.
Big Momma.
Michelle, he tried to turn America into a
socialist society.
What's one example of a socialist policy that
he had socialized health care?
He didn't do that for profit.
Obama taking care of everybody else by getting
rid of jobs.
Many people took
Speaker 1: care of people by getting rid of
more
Speaker 3: time jobs, and they had to work
two part time jobs in order to survive.
Just so you don't even understand the talking
points, the rest stop working and just a dependent
and reliant on the government free Obama for.
That's socialism, socialism.
So how can you say Obama Obama's socialism?
Speaker 1: I want to ask a real question.
Speaker 3: I'm asking you a real question.
Speaker 1: Obama phones are not socialism.
Now, answer your question.
Let me ask you this.
I really want to know this.
The arguments against places like Venezuela
and Cuba and other so-called socialist countries
are that no one has anything.
No one can afford anything.
There is no technology.
There's no food.
But you're saying that cell phones for people
or socialism,
Speaker 3: is that that's your argument?
Yeah.
All right.
How about an example of it?
Speaker 1: Yeah, so the point is there's no
difference here.
They don't know what socialism is.
They don't know what critical race theory
is.
The first step in every single one of these
conversations should be.
Ask them to define the terms and you will
very quickly see that they have no idea what
they are talking about.